welcome to this video this is a rapid
game yes I'm playing some of those
longer time control games again and I
wanted to try out the option of playing
it on chess calm the reason is they have
a sort of auto pairing system there for
15 minutes plus 10 second increment the
10 second it's a bit much I mean five
second would be okay just to have this
little increment to finish game in a
logical way and not have yeah people
playing on time after you have fought
there for 30 minutes and then you lose
like with two seconds on the clock
against the one second with Luke against
Luke no yeah the catches my rating is
really really low I need to gain points
I I don't think i have a plate here
maybe one or two games so that it's not
such an even number like 1800 or so um
okay we transpose back to an Enzo it was
a bogo Indian playing their death on e
from from the UK let's see what we get
here d 5 that's an interesting option
harm so I'm going to play it in benoni
fashion like taking or I can also take
on c3 give them the doubled pawns more
d6 also possible
yeah then let's start with that it's not
really um a mainline this d5 push what
option is always to get into an S
mentioned a benoni type of structure
with Ed CD with the funny bishop
placement on before which is not that
bad actually it sometimes can come
around like after b-52 b6 ok he went
Bishop g5 i think i think i will kick
him once asking him about his intentions
yeah so now I have more than one option
I can still take on d5 wow this doorbell
is really loud I can still take on d5
going from the the Benoni structure I
can also take on see if replayy 54 close
game get both the viable option I'm
going to to play for the more open
position this is maybe a little bit more
interesting ok I'm so sell some point
here not to cancel or delay it or what
not I don't think so probably just
canceling
you know what is my my setup probably
what I want to do is I want to prepare a
6b five this would be nice expand on the
queenside and the other thing that I
normally want to do is to regroup my
night my night on be ate some yeah it's
set at home and it has a good square
actually on g6 like rook e8 night d 79 f
896 this is an idea um still do i earn
how do I want to play it in terms of
move autumn and I can start with 97
maybe
or look 38 still yeah maybe let's start
with that it's probably not a huge
difference the Rope belong see em on yet
anyway if he goes I wonder if he goes in
Bishop d3 here maybe can play g5 and
grab I am so not not on the arg 594 here
in the sim does seem very very loose so
probably not I'd like to get in a 6 also
maybe mmmm in some situation he has the
square one be 50 that's interesting he's
not playing a for him hmm okay yeah okay
if I go b5 now he has a form to a check
it yeah okay not but not necessarily i
can start with 97 and prepare for the
regrouping like fa to g6 get the main
virtue of the night on g6 is that it
it's if you want a little bit out of the
way so I can play Bishop e7 maybe
support be five or the queenside
expansion sometimes the night on g6 is
also useful piece to block any white
play on them on the King side note that
with this early pressure along the
before you one diagonal on the king it
wasn't possible for him to set up a
broad center with e4 like it is in the
in the normal benoni with the fianchetto
so that's something that my position um
has going for it it's not so on so so
quick this expansion yeah what should
why do I mean a4 is like very obvious no
it's going to d3
ha and that I didn't expect really Oh
what's the Queen doing down yeah I
wonder if night f8 g6 is still the right
idea queen bee three it is very tempting
now to play be five maybe get in c4 with
the temple ha well I but ok I need to be
cautious I quick c4 also frees the
default square for is night to come to
come to deform and bb5 a 4c form I can
definitely play that it's not not bad
hmm
okay let's let's go ahead and the Queen
on d3 really there's a little bit of a
provocation trying to reduce the Circe
44 idea but it's what I want to do in
the long run maybe i can actually yeah
this was clear I wonder is there some
other way to play here like the group be
a door something to cover this in a
technical way b5 maybe but ok this is
still nice one reason why this is ok I
believe is that the queen is not having
a great square this is one possible
square but it's still not not really
great yeah how to do this a b5 is of
course a threat yeah I was actually
thinking I can take him
and Bishop be 72 trying to win the porn
simply let's try that yeah i mean the d5
pole is under under some pressure with
c4 i was making sure that there is no
kind of protection coming from a
capturing porn on c3 and yeah this is
what i was thinking before I can really
just take I mean rook takes but if he
plays let's say rook the one now I'm
going to play Queen B 6 and ask him how
he how is he going to protected maybe
Queen at five sometime k grabs there so
I'm going to recapture rook takes
there's also Queen takes for additional
pressure on d5 I am ok this one
attacking be five yeah possibly rook be
one as an annoying with I see
your gal queen bee six was my original
IDM but ok can just go Rupe you one
yeah it was it was clear that it's not
not that easy but this looks rather
uncomfortable well now that wasn't a
good idea really what I played him the
sea for business I can take g5 and maybe
I must do that actually exchanged de
pomme de pont for a beep on but it's not
very great I mean not really now I
cannot really protect this well not good
yeah whitey just has a quite quite
significant advantage the remaining
pieces will be just in his favor the
night on deform I mean he will take now
1b5 engine then just drop back to deform
which is great and it's not I really
don't really have any great thing going
for me maybe i can i can now this is
actually an idea i can trade and play
Queen B 6 with the temple he cannot go
rook be one because of bit early form a
little little trick and maybe yeah maybe
it is still okay not very not great but
maybe okay night 2d fall back I can just
drop back to the form for a good
position yeah i was thinking here and
maybe d5
yeah there yeah maybe I can still hold
on but white is definitely better him
okay I guess d5 yeah I move like f3
taking my bishop this is of course
something then I like to see I get back
to g6 and III will be a weakness and an
unnecessary weakness nothing that he
needed to do maybe queen bee to I Betsy
forum was hanging so yeah but queen bee
to this may be an idea that I have there
is some just one weakness in his camp
this is the c3 porn this is currently
unprotected so maybe queen bee to can
harass am a bit but it's yeah it's
nothing great you know even just going
Quincy one this sum is okay for white
yeah but ok it's not it's not like it's
super clear what you should do I mean I
think I'm it's definitely comfortable
but but what exactly are you playing our
slide the night is already great on
deform yeah but that ok the bishops
White's bishops don't have any any great
stuff to do and I maybe have 95 to d3
those kind of things maybe I'm not in
such a bad shape and there was a little
bit too that's a mistake at first yeah
I'm not saying I better or anything but
maybe this is not that bad I was
thinking that um I wasn't nothing but
some trouble but it seems that the
remaining pieces are quite ok and I have
some ideas and what exactly is why it's
doing here what is White's IDM but it's
not that easy as mentioned the bishops
here e 2 or g3 they are not or possibly
going to g3 they are not really doing
much like attacking something
significant or putting any huge pressure
on me
hmm quite curious
I'm not easy to play at all I don't see
a great move forward maybe he can
somehow someone activate his rook or
queen a for tween 87 those kind of idea
but I always have this queen bee to move
ha maybe I'm in cried okay shape here
yeah it seems like I'm talking myself
into believing that that I'm actually in
great shape I don't know what should i
do him I don't don't see a good plan to
be honest i also have a good Bishop yani
for always controlling be one okay now I
have an idea maybe Quincy one Queen a
three playing on dark squares and
possibly going for Queen a7 and so on
this is actually an idea okay so he
decided to do after all we can this III
m pawn and yeah he can't play yeah this
I was thinking about this idea but
ultimately I couldn't really believe
that it is that great efore might be an
area trying to free this this Bishop now
but I have a good a good controller now
I wonder if i should go Quinn be 20 if
this is not leading to anything the
other thing to consider is of course
Izzy formed and a possible night
discovery is this any great
otherwise I mean 95 95 or c 5 and then
Bishop d3 would be great getting getting
in night to d3 ultimately if I go queen
bee to hear he just plays Quincy one and
I'm going nowhere right if five there's
also F 493 f5 but then I can take can
take 1 F 2 a.m. okay let's do that i
think ii form i can really just take the
pawn on e4 there is no there is no
discovery by this night on deform on my
queen that looks som that looks
dangerous and in an ideal scenario i
would like to play Bishop d3 exchange
the lightscribe bishops and then come to
the three with a night which stays down
if I just put the night there you can
take it and it's not so clear that I
benefited from that very much okay so
Queen a for attacking my rook on e 8
that means i need to be a bit cautious I
shouldn't I mean with moving 19 on f6 or
things like that otherwise it's nothing
really threatening queen bee to also in
the mix okay i'm going to going to try
this stranger he has a hard time to
avoid that I mean he can play Bishop you
one but this looks like we had
another thing that I could place queen
bee to but it's not leading to much you
can play Queen a three for example to
cover c3 and offer the Queen trade yeah
well I mean Bishop t1 looks weird but
maybe you should still still should do
that maybe I don't know it does not look
good too to allow a night on d3 which
really really really would be really
strong and she does not have a tactic to
remove the f6 night so that my rook is
hanging on the aid yeah I mean stuff
like Bishop H form if everything fails i
play g5 but only really if everything
else fails
yeah on a moon flatbush ave shoulders
alsobrook be a gem that's not a bad
place for the rook but okay I don't
expect this move in any case Bishop each
was also possibility maybe after that I
don't know I actually think he should
okay so he's allowing always offering
the Queen trade him um yeah should i do
that or not if I trade Queen takes rook
takes Bishop e2 92 93 m so this is not
bad yeah not bad but i still wonder twin
be too maybe can I do that invasion
queen bee to queen bee to Queen a three
rock p8 maybe for more activity i
thought that looks more promising
actually and the queen is not doing that
much on a six so i probably should do
that it looks looks fine right if you go
screen 8 a-3 now I don't have time to
win the peas on youtube but I can play a
rook v8 which actually threatens on each
other and here i can grab the pond and i
think i want i am that kind of greedy
person oh wait wait wait not so quick if
i take it huh Bishop you one are you
kidding there should be one and my queen
s no square that's funny don't tell me
you plant that yeah Queen c3 Bishop you
want and let's let
not screw this up I really have no
square down hmm funny I have no square
that's cool ok so I'm going to play
rugby idea ha did you really plan that
that's cool ok so would be 8 as
originally intended after Queen a 3 if
he takes now rook takes his bishop only
two is directly on the check and after
caption night takes I'm really I'm
really in a dangerous position with my
night on the three ad looks looks not
easy to play against so let's see and
now I'm actually threatening to take on
c3 as after possible bishop you've won I
can just drop back to be too so we had
does not really have a slow move ok but
I'm also threatening Bishop e2 92 Queen
a to rook a 2 rupee one check winning a
piece so there are there are some
concrete things going on he cannot just
play whatever move
I'm wondering if there is a tactic you
know it is looking a lot like there
might be a tactic stuff like we need to
look at you look be one check King f2
and then those checks on g4 ad form
isn't there some sort of tactic no chief
exec TX 94 check king of three ah it's
at least the perpetual it's probably not
more
when night is also hanging that's
important to know it
wait wait wait there is a win yeah there
is a win I just need to calculate are
almost wait maybe not okay come on I'm
going to going to play the first moves
or not is this is there it's very
unlikely that there's something better
so I'm going to take here give this
check and now what I was thinking is of
course he has to play king f2 right
Nyjah for check takes nightie for check
King f3 Bishop e2 check Knight takes
rook f1 is winning King takes Knight c3
is also winning so rook takes rook takes
rook f1 check Bishop f2 I mean and there
is no win how to believe but maybe it is
the case hmm
94 takes if i take Ferno takes here king
of three takes it to look takes f1 check
half this really really not winning that
that's very hard to believe if i give
this check check here no one can also
take on c3 but he always has an
intermediate check as well the two
checks
ah am i overlooking something here or am
I just expecting things that are that
are not them simply or is there a
different something different to check
king of three
you should take some tags check you
should have to I don't see a
continuation now looks very awkward for
white but maybe there is there is
nothing it's possible okay if I take F 3
i'm sorry if i take e to you will
probably just take on air only 5 which
is not great but where do I go with my
night is there some way to prepare the
whole thing does this kind of tactic I
don't think so
it's a real shame it feels like it
should work but it doesn't it somehow
doesn't okay so what actually am I
playing Knight to d7 something like that
possibly night to c5
I don't know yeah I'm down 13 minutes I
mean it is not that dramatic because of
the increment but but still yeah I was
really hoping that once the position is
on the board I would find something
along those Knight g4 lines but I didn't
see anything it does not it does not
seem to win simply okay yeah well here
he can what what can you do actually
give give a check or maybe what he can
maybe he can just take a five-player
form trying to reduce the pressure but I
feel I still think that I'm threatening
to take on e 2 and play 93 which is
still quite annoying so I don't know if
he has anything great going from him
yeah we'll check king age seven there's
nothing great happening here taking is
not working at it with checking a 2 nite
c 1 wins the rook so we cannot take him
yeah maybe it's not a bad idea to just
just take e5 and player form trying to
simplify the situation for white it's
not that easy you cannot like play ok
five or something this is not a good
idea i have looked be 21 taking 93 is
still nishio maybe look a look at seven
maybe but what exactly is this doing
yeah dunno probably should redo I would
probably tend to tend to do something
very simple i take this f4 to make the
whole situation more manageable but
that's definitely not a refutation or
anything if he goes what is the body
about f4 f4 I think about f4 Bishop e2 f
takes a fire but probably not that great
i just go back to back to d3 threaten ii
will get one mate so yeah I really don't
know it's not very apparent what why
should do him
yeah as mentioned i don't really think
that Bishop takes d5 should be the best
move yeah yeah i was thinking i just
take on e2 yeah i will just take him yep
come on let's probably just write fe5
Bishop d3 is should be great a
threatened rook f1 made and a half 95
for coming so yeah he needs to to
recapture now and then i can jump to d3
it's really a question if F for blocking
his Bishop is such a great IDM I doubt
that relay and I have Knight f6 you form
as some additional options yeah and
that's like that that looks good for for
for black right okay um do I jump to d3
I guess yeah yeah that must be right
threatening night see one the night is
certainly a problem and i still have
Knight f6 to e4 night c 5 24 and if i
get two nights on e4 in d3 does this
should be the end of it I mean this
looks like too much when I when I get
there and he only has still still
relatively meaningless checks so
just just just go into age 7 he's
basically playing without the bishop
yeah the bishop is just not a great
piece and if he goes if he leaves the
second-ranked with his rook I always
have looked be too which is nice to have
Luke on the second rank now that will be
very difficult to defend plus there's
9c1 check which is something to attend
to here immediately
I'm Kim okay he ignored this this one
mover when the clock was ticking down so
I'm going to win this win this rook yeah
he defended defended okay actually
difficult yeah very difficult very
difficult position let's do a quick
quick recap here we go back a couple of
moves I was actually surprised that that
this sum was was better than I then I
expected originally like exactly here
maybe we start the analysis here yeah I
round here I was thinking that I'm good
as at first but there is a really it
does not seem to be anything great going
going on maybe queen a for things like
that it's nothing great I still have a
very decent position yeah so f three
went back I'm really curious about one
or two things around here I definitely
am okay here maybe I should consider to
just take him just take him and go for
this which is definitely not a bad thing
to have this is kind of structure but of
course I was tempted by this Queen Saudi
and he defended this with Queenie too
funny enough to cause this is like very
embarrassing funny yeah but ok rock PA
this is good not this but rugby aid then
he went should be three
yeah I know this funny situation I was
really thinking that this should should
leak somewhere but there is no win here
I mean there are things that win like
that it's quite funny or King takes
obviously also come on do this but here
ya can take with the rook and after this
check there is no way forward here he's
like somewhat in disarray but i have no
half no move now that that gets me
anywhere oh really curious so I went
went to I went with this he went f1 yeah
here I don't know f4 is not good but I
was thinking just to do something simple
like this and play at four hour or maybe
this it should be about equal but f-for
is not good I think and probably i mean
what i did is ok but there is also this
move by the way which I'm just seeing
him was made which means that he cannot
take it it has to go here and it looks
kinda shaky maybe age 5 or 90 of six
threatening made this was probably
probably a much better mood ok but I
didn't see that I was I was not seeing
that at all I went with the capture yeah
TM I mean black is better here mostly
because he has this somewhat silly
bishop on g 3 which will be am simply
worse than the Knights which will enter
enter like that one of those two routes
but he blundered the rook of course
which makes things much easier I think
it would have been difficult for white
in the long run to be honest it's not
like totally terrible but but difficult
to play maybe maybe you should try
something like that with some sort of
activity but if we look at that this is
going to be going to be very difficult
especially in a practical game difficult
yeah I hope you enjoyed this longer game
longer time control game a rapid time
control and it was an interesting game
which left me some more room to explain
the ideas and considerations I hope you
enjoyed it and I will do this once in a
while thanks for watching